here's what would happen if you fell
into Lake nios this 210 meter deep lake
lies in Northwest Cameroon in Africa
over a volcanic crater it's one of Only
Three Lakes that accumulates deadly
levels of carbon dioxide as you sank
into the deadly Waters dissolved carbon
dioxide would rise to the surface Lake
nios would bubble causing even more
turbulence then a 90 meter water jet
would explode Skyward sending you flying
as high as London's Big Ben in 20
seconds a one kilometer wide gas cloud
would be Unleashed it would spread for
25 kilometers at a speed of 48
kilometers per hour an event like this
happened in 1986 when a limnic eruption
on Lake nios killed
1746 villagers and 3 500 livestock have
you ever seen the famous Diet Coke and
Mentos eruption yeah that would be you